it's so much in my memory the look on
that little boy's face I think about
that little boy every single day working
at Pixar you have to put yourself out
there you have to be willing to fail you
know even though it's never been done
before it doesn't mean it can't be done
honestly we put more pressure on
ourselves to make good movies for our
audience than anybody you know any kind
of pressure from the outside he's an
American animator film director and
chief creative officer of Pixar and Walt
Disney Animation Studios he oversees all
of Pixar's films and associated projects
as executive producer he has an
estimated net worth of a hundred million
dollars he's John Lasseter and here is
my take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
I make sure to stick around although to
the end for some special bonus clips
also as John is talkin if he says
something that really resonates with you
please leave in the comments below and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
everybody has their own kind of sense of
accomplishment what unisom opening
weekend box office or winning Academy
Awards to me it is being in an audience
anonymously and watching people watch my
movies and seeing how we're entertaining
people the first true experience I ever
had of that was about five days after
Toy Story came out took four years for
me to make Toy Story all of us at Pixar
and I was flying with my family we were
changing planes in the dallas-fort Worth
Airport I got off the plane and there
was a little boy about four years old
with his mother and he was holding a
woody the cowboy doll and it's the first
time I'd seen one of my characters
outside of Pixar and I was so stunned my
boys that looked like the look on his
face he couldn't wait to show his father
who was getting off the plane his toy
and I realized at that moment that that
character that I with the help of
everybody Pixar created over four years
no longer belonged to me it belonged to
him and I to be honest it's so it's so
much in my memory the look on that
little boy's face I think about that
little boy every single day working at
Pixar NASA why we do what we do to
create something that connects with
people that moves people is the most
fulfilling and satisfying work there is
for an artist it is it is truly a
privilege to do this for a living
but with that privilege comes
responsibility and the privilege and
responsibility are one in the same to do
something new I say that it is a
responsibility because to really truly
be creative you have to be willing to
take risks you have to put yourself out
there you have to be willing to fail
failure has such a negative connotation
in our society and I think
this is totally unfair because what
failure really is is the opportunity to
learn if we never failed it would never
occur to us to do things differently you
would just keep doing the same thing
because it would always work but the
world it changes people change and so we
have to change we have to fail in order
to succeed I think the biggest thing for
us is that we studied films we watched
films religiously we were making we with
Toy Story it was a buddy picture we
watched everybody picture we could find
and analyzed it good ones and it's very
important to watch bad ones to know
seriously is very important you watch a
bunch of good ones and watch a few bad
ones and pretty soon you'll start seeing
huh this one Defiant ones did this I'm
not going to say it these other films
did that and that's why it doesn't quite
work interesting ok and you start
understanding what they did any more and
more and it don't copy things it's about
understanding and learning be thirsty
for knowledge be thirsty for knowledge
it will always make your work better I
believe so strongly that no matter what
you do create the best quality you can
in whatever you do quality is the best
business plan it's the only business
plan I've ever lived
Pixar up is going to be it's our tenth
movie and it's it's a record in
Hollywood that's on it that's unlike any
anyone any record that anyone's ever
seen ten successes in a row so quality
is best was one and we surround
ourselves with absolutely the best
people and I believe very strongly in
this there's so often you will find
yourself in a situation where there is a
hierarchy that ideas are important
because of who is saying them because
they have a higher position than you I
believe very strongly it doesn't
matter whose idea it is the best idea
Epic's are we always use the ideas come
from the reception's
they come from the cooks they come from
everybody and we use them because it's
everybody's there to make the movies
better our people are so good right now
and they're so accomplished and our
technology has grown so much that you
know and that's what Pixar's about it's
like everyone who picks our lives for
that day that will come to him sick you
know we don't know how to do this here
try to figure it out they live for that
is they kissing what's what's
interesting about Pixar and I think it's
really a product from Northern
California so Silicon Valley Steve Jobs
George Lucas it's it's all this this
belief that that you know even though
it's never been done before it doesn't
mean it can't be done
right there's no one here that says that
can't be done right and every movie
we've made there's aspects of it that no
one's ever is something unlike anything
you've ever seen before even the sequels
you know you look at all the you know
Toy Story and Toy Story 2 and Toy Story
3 and tell you there's things in both of
those sequels that are unlike anything
that's been done before it and I think
definitely looking at cars and cars - I
don't think there's this you know
they're so different you know in kind of
the look and feel Mark Twain once said
the two most important days of your life
or the day you were born and the day you
find out why the first of those has
already happened to you because you're
sitting right here okay
the second the day that you find out why
you're born may have already happened to
many of you and to the others not yet
but you will know when it happens it
will be connected to something that you
truly love
I've always said to my five sons choose
something that you love to do and you'll
never work a day in your life
is that every time you do something for
the first time a paper a movie the story
of script you know whatever chances are
the first time the first pass is is
going to be wrong so I understand coin
this phrase we use all the time Pixar be
wrong as fast as you can get it up there
be wrong as fast as you can because then
with honesty around you you'll get to
being write much quicker very very very
important do not work in a vacuum do not
work in a vacuum right you may be either
filmmaker and doing something wrong but
you have to surround yourself with
trusted people you have to you know you
get so immersed in your work you will
everybody does you get so immersed in in
your work I guarantee you you will you
will not be able to see the forest from
the trees frankly you'll be stunning the
pine needles and worrying about them and
you need someone to help you back up and
take a look at the forest and see where
things are working or not working and
you need to surround yourself with
people whose judgment you trust and they
can be brutally honest with you
and you have to be able to look showing
as an artist showing unfinished work to
people is really difficult is really
hard
it always is hard it always will be hard
it never gets any easier but you have to
do it you know it's funny wait we
already asked see how how do you cope
with a pressure you know do you feel the
pressure
honestly we put more pressure on
ourselves to make good movies for our
audience than anybody you know any kind
of pressure from the outside you know we
it was very important for me when Bob
Iger and Steve Jobs agreed to let Disney
by Pixar and merge
to companies then they asked me to
become chief creative officer of Disney
Animation as well as continue doing that
with Pixar Animation and I came home to
Disney and I just like coming home
really because it's all I've always you
know done things I've always wanted to
work for Walt Disney when I was a kid
and be a Disney animator and I've loved
everything about Disney and even at
Pixar made movies in the style of Walt
Disney and coming home to Disney to me
the goal was to to make this studio make
great movies again if that truly deeply
entertained audiences to put the the
filmmakers the artists the animators the
story people kind of creatively in
charge you know of these films again not
let these executives tell them what to
do let the artists the filmmakers it's
why they are there you know and but to
challenge them to make these films great
and to me I will never you know it takes
four years to make one an animated film
and you have every chance this is what I
say you have every chance to do a right
you know and and I am so dedicated to
making sure that it's that it's good
movies out there and that that's why we
you know we have a good track record
because we have this belief that we can
do it and we will do it you know in your
life you will start a job and there's
what I say to every single new person
coming into picture no matter what you
do make yourself indispensable to that
organization make yourself indispensable
we're people after you're done with your
job people cannot imagine the place
without you and without asking for a
thing your career will be set
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because chai 10 Joshi
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know which of the rules had the
biggest impact on you and why what
change your you going to immediately
make to your life or business after
watching this video please leave in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout out to Kevin Lee Kevin thank you
so much for picked up a copy of my book
coming in to get an autograph and then
post it on Facebook I really really
really appreciate the support and the
love so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
you know one of the exciting things
about the merger between Disney and
Pixar and Bob Iger making the chief
creative officer and Ed Catmull
president of the Walt Disney animation
studio was it went the first thing that
we want to do when we came came into the
studio is we wanted to start production
on a hand-drawn animated film I loved
the medium of hand-drawn animation I
loved it I think it's fantastic and I
never quite understood why Animation
Studios like all around you know
especially in in Hollywood but all
around the world we're deciding that
people audiences weren't interested in
watching hand-drawn animation anymore
the way I look at it is like okay think
of two movie studios that are making
live-action films one makes really
popular films and the other one just
so-so films the soso film studio we kind
of look over and go oh I get it I know
why your films are not doing well at the
box office we're using the wrong camera
we're going to use that camera whether
that company that's film studio that's
doing amazing work you know and now our
movies are going to be liked by
audiences now of course that's
ridiculous but that's the way we feel
about hand-drawn animation versus
computer animation never in the history
of cinema has a movie been entertaining
to an audience because of the technology
it is what you do with the technology
it's what you do with a medium it's so
special I understand you know said this
and I think it's a perfect sentiment is
that 2d animation became the scapegoat
for bad storytelling well the audience
just don't want to watch his bad movies
right they like watching good movies the
thing I always tell students that really
wanted to work in animation or work in
film for that
is do not forget to study the basics
basic drawing even for computer
animation you should know how to draw
basic design the basic fundamentals of
animation where you learn the principles
of animation film grammar how do you
stage things you know that you know how
they do it in live-action filmmaking
story writing three active story
structure is so vital to this and if
you've got to learn all these basics
because this is kind of like eating
vegetables you know a lot of people
don't want to do it they just get on to
the more flashy stuff of using all the
latest software but the thing is is
through your career the software will
change it will always evolve and get
better what's important in remember this
software never makes a movie
entertaining is what you do with a
software and what you do with a software
it will be will be
you know you'll learn that from the
basic fundamentals you know I rely on
these the basic fundamentals of art and
design and filmmaking and animation and
storytelling you know every single day
of my career it's something that just is
a part of use the foundation in which
you work and without those you know you
won't go anywhere so it's really
important to get the fundamentals down
I loved animation I knew it was not just
for kids Walt Disney never made his
movies just for kids he made them for
everybody
Chuck Jones made his cartoons to show in
theaters in front of Warner Brothers
movies for adults but I felt it had to
be done for today's audience it had to
be done in a new way I found the answer
when I was working at Disney computer
animation I knew this was it I knew this
was the future you see one of the things
that that I
was admired about Walt Disney was his
innovative spirit Walt had been a great
advocate of the new and many
groundbreaking developments of film
technology had their origins at his
studio I threw myself into suggesting
projects that would show how the
computer could be used to take Disney
Disney animation to the next level I
even did a test I kept getting the
answers no that's not how it's done is
it cheaper is it faster then no just do
what you're told no one was willing to
take risks but that didn't stop me I
kept trying I just couldn't let go of
the idea that computer animation was
something Disney should be doing because
I knew it make this studio and its films
better then one day the manager of the
animation department mr. noh himself
called me into his office and fired me
to be fired from the place of your
dreams was so painful and embarrassing
for me that it took decades before I
could actually tell people about it
I made this kind of excuse up that I
followed my dream somewhere else
even as I got married I it took me you a
long time to tell Nancy Etta actually
get my wife I had actually gotten fired
but as fate would have it I met edy
camel of the Lucas home computer
division he and his group were doing the
most innovative research in the world in
computer graphics and unlike the Disney
that just fired me edy was so excited
about what I was trying to do to combine
classic animation principles to computer
animation I finally found someone who
could see the future as I saw it he
invited me to come work with him then in
1986 Steve Jobs entered our lives he was
so excited about what he what we were
trying to do
to Daddy that he bought our group from
Lucasfilm and we formed a new company
called Pixar he really pushed us to do
what no one else had ever done before
the result in 1995 we released the first
computer animated feature film ever made
we released Toy Story
[Applause]